what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves yet
another trailer for Spider-Man across
the spider verse we're working on a
Creed 3 reaction at it that's right I'm
plugging something coming up this week
guys that's how you YouTube and now
John's here what's up John welcome to a
one in the morning shoot how you doing
buddy I am I'm energized I'm jacked up
and ready to Traverse the spider verse
I'm excited I did not actually see the
one that you covered with koi
um before this is gonna be very fresh
for me oh good I'm excited for you
me too Swip that like button let's get
to it
[Music]
only Spiderman and things are going
great oh yeah you're supposed to be here
all right whatever whatever
oh man
I am the spot yep it's not funny
don't do that
miles is great they're pretty good
that's my little man and a B in Spanish
he's lying to you and I think you know
it
spot gonna be like the main village it
looks like it or at least a big Force
wanna get out of here
wait a minute there's an elite crew with
all the best that's a good troop who's
the new guy oh no way spider
oh there's the Iron Spider
the whole thing was his idea what's it I
gotta do to join this spider team you
can
[Music]
I'll take it from here
miles
and saved in every world
trolley problem I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always
Uncle Ben most of us wouldn't be
[Music]
God this looks freaking epic yeah this
isn't what we talked about wow I had no
idea how are you doing everyone holy
you're so Ted's supposed to go
nah I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
spider therapy
oh
we're going like 22 Jump Street terrain
at that point oh so much I mean the
ending of 22 Jump Street oh wow that was
overwhelming I saw Spider-Man no way
home three times in the theaters I saw
into the spider-verse three times in
theaters needless to say I'm a
Spider-Man fan not this guy hates
Spider-Man but all about that morbius
train I think this trailer was beautiful
because it provided all the Vivid wild
imaginative fun that I want from this
movie it managed to communicate both
emotions in this trailer where it felt
very expressive and massive like the
scales seem so much bigger yet it still
had this very personal Stakes touch at
least what I was picking up on here I'm
not exactly sure what the movie's main
inner conflict is going to be dealing
with but from what it seemed like they
were teasing among amidst the chaos he's
torn between a choice where he has to
kind of allow his dad to die you know
there are all these things about letting
Uncle Ben die and it seems like uh you
know but part of what the trajectory has
to be is allow Wing Jefferson Davis to
die but and but yet you know he does
have that moment where he's interacting
with Miguel O'Hara saying that you know
people keep saying how my story is
supposed to go but I'm gonna I'm gonna
dictate how I'm gonna let it play out
and then they were referencing no way
home you know was all about trying to
like control the way events went down I
loved that possibility of him having to
deal with such a personal choice because
you got to keep a person because I don't
think the first movie did so well was
allowing yeah you got all these
Spider-Man characters you got all these
references you got all this great
animation and everything but they still
managed to be a really strong Miles
Morales story I think that they found
like a good core there which will create
some real tough choices there are parts
of this where the conflict with Miguel
O'Hara and Miles Morales some reminded
me of doctor strange and engine
how it's supposed to go down yeah we're
dealing with the interdimensional with
this stuff it's not about you it's about
the greater good it's about all the
Multiverse it's not just this universe
yeah but it still looked very very fun
because yeah it's Easter eggs Galore up
in here I loved it I thought that was
awesome I had just chills throughout
this looked like rousing yeah no it was
like super rich like it's almost like a
dense little short film in unto itself
because like spider-verse has a
wonderfully overwhelming quality about
it where yeah there's so much visual
expression but there's also a ton of
emotional expression and this had both
uh flavors kind of an equal measure all
the fun all the you know varying
different uh arrays of Spider-Man that
we're gonna see but also it seems like
this will be incredibly difficult in
terms of the personal Journey not only
for the idea that he might have to let
Jefferson die in order to secure the
greater good but you know his
entanglement with Gwen and you know her
reaching out across universes to get to
him and not wanting to probably lose
that and then coming into what seemed
like a big amount of conflict with not
only Miguel O'Hara but at least a
certain amount of the Spider-Man who are
probably on his particular wavelengths
yeah it almost seems like you know
they're gonna take that coming of age
even further and having that you know uh
sort of stubbornness to say no I'm going
to dictate how the story ends I feel
like there was a lot of great potential
for growth for miles in that but also a
lot of potential for tragedy and I feel
like one thing Lord and Miller and their
you know cohorts are really good at are
giving us things that are both fun but
meaningful and that will kind of have
that weight and have that challenge in
it like what I wasn't expecting was like
the spot in this is like so impish and
so kind of whimsical in his presence and
I was coming in thinking like oh that's
going to be the main villain but here it
more looks like an internal conflict
between Miguel and miles and everybody
else it seems like spot probably creates
some because he's like an
interdimensional villain yeah and it
seems like by accident he creates a
problem sure that they have to fix
because there's something that feels
like really goofy I mean spot so it
seems like they're they're leaning into
a comedic side of what causes this you
know Universal scale to deal with
um versus just a massive meaningful
menacing threat you know sure
um but I thought it was great I mean
yeah you got you got some great
references here to all the other
Spider-Man and I saw images of the the
previous trailer so it looks like
they've done a lot of that here I really
thought that was a spider Punk right on
the guitar I believe so yeah yeah I've
been trying to skim this while John was
talking and I'm like I cannot find that
image there's so many images
this will be on every Easter eggs break
down like all 155 Spider-Man and women
that appear in this trailer and yet it
was another thing that I sort of
gathered from part of its emotional core
was him having more of a relationship
Dynamic with his mom this time around
yeah uh not that she wasn't important in
the first one but so much of the first
one had a father and son tale and this
seems like it'll have a little bit more
to do with his mom but Miguel O'Hara man
that he I don't trust him yeah I know
that was the last thing I was expecting
I mean he's come across as you know like
brooding and intense in the previous
little flashes that we've seen in the
previous trailer but here it it does
look like he is like going mad trying to
hold this whole operation together and
might be crossing over potentially into
extreme territory that might be you know
beyond the pale of what's truly moral
what is you know left up to that great
responsibility you know and Peter B
Parker is back with a baby he's back so
many Peter's B Parker at one of their
Con in there guys what did you think
about this trailer I thought it was
awesome yeah I cannot wait for this
there's a theater one oh we're not gonna
react to that here I'm gonna watch the
theaters I'll pay someone else
I'll do it I hate Spider-Man I know all
right guys well what did you think about
this trailer leave your thoughts down
below be sure to subscribe leave a like
and hey while we're here this hour let's
end this with a
Anisa Oliva if I was to travel the
Multiverse to discover a whole bunch of
other nieces I will want to meet all the
Anisa variants I'd want to meet
black Anissa oh yeah I want to meet
Japanese Nisa Japanese I wanted to meet
Chinese Nisa I would want to meet South
African Nisa I'd want to meet Tech
though you are from Texas I don't want
to meet
Utah
yeah yeah how different would she be
from Texas Nisa I want to meet New York
Nissan I want to meet Canada nice Canada
Nisa I want to meet uh Bulgarian Nissan
yeah Amsterdam Anisa I want to meet
turkey Nissan oh yeah uh Jupiter I want
to meet North Dakota Nissan yeah
and I want them all to come across
exactly the same sure I don't want there
to be any discernible differences here
in Nexus being because I'm not racist I
want them all to come across exactly the
same yes I want Chinese Nisa to be
speaking Spanish it's just like
ours yeah I'm saying y'all a lot this is
the Texas accent yeah because Nissa
I want to travel the Anisa verse Oh
across the Anisa version John would take
them all out on dates dates trying to
find the perfect Anisa to marry oh
that's a high concept movie I found the
perfect woman but it's women but I have
I can't decide which variant is the best
it's the best one to be and he's gonna
have to choose between which one of the
anisas all of them I can't shoot how
could I possibly go with Blackness
Blackness
black nieces for me
it's Anisa from Texas and blackface it's
a really racist thing and for some
reason John's really the Heart Wants
What It Wants orbius and blackface
[Music]